[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار الظهيره
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
عسكري السابق بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
واثنين من مرافقه بقصف تركي في القامشلي
واشنطن تحث انقره على وقف التصعيد شمال
سوريا والعراق ينشر قواته على الحدود مع
ايران وتركيا
طهران تصاعدوا من قمع المتظاهرين ومجلس
حقوق الانسان الاممي والبرلمان الاوروبيه
بحساني الانتهاكات
حالته ظهرا واحتجاجات عنيفه في مدينه
صينيه والسلطات تفرض اغلاقا عاما لمكافحه
كورونا
مشاهدينا نبدا بالتطورات في سوريا قتل
وزير الدفاع السابق لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه رزان كلو اثنين من مرافقيه في
قصف القوات التركيه على مدينه القامشلي
طبعا الشمالي سوريا مصادر اهليه لوكاله
سبوتنا كفادت ان كله كان يستقله سيارات
بيك اب للتمويه عندما قصفت طائره مسيره
تابعه للقوات التركيه سيارته في القامشلي
الى ذلك ذكرت المصادر القوات التركيه قصفت
ايضا مشفا للكورونا وهو ايضا تابع لقصد في
الحزام الغربي للمدينه مدينه قامشلي وذلك
بقذيفه من طائره مسيره اضافه الى سقوط
قديفتين على ميسلون شمال شرقيه مركز مدينه
القامشلي
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من القامشلي مراسل العربيه
اخر التطورات الميدانيه المعلومات
المتوفره لديك ويقال انه هذه الايام هي
الايام المسيرات والطائرات المسيره
بامتياز
مرحبا
المشاهدين ليله امس كانت ليلى ساخنه في
عموم شمال شرق سوريا تحديدا في اقليم
الجزيره المسيرات التركيه استهدفت 13 موقع
في في مدينه القامشلي
ومحيطها احدا هذه الغارات استهدفت القيادي
الكردي البارز رزان جلو وهو وزير الدفاع
السابق في الاداره الاساسيه اليوم صباحا
تواصلنا مع المستشفى العسكري الذي يعالج
فيه رزان وصلنا معلومات مؤكده بان رزان
قولوا لا يزال على قيد الحياه لكنه حالته
خطيره ويعاني من الجروح بليغه ليله امس
الساعه 10:00 صباحا مساءا بالتوقيت
المحلي تم استهداف في هذا الدوار الذي همم
في همم الان مع اثنين من مرافقه حالتهم
ايضا همم صعبه ثم استهداف يعني الحزام
الغربي بعدم قذائف من المسيارات
التركيه عموما كانت يعني ليله القامشلي
ليلى ساخنه عاش فيها السكان الليله ظلمه
حيث انقطعت الكهرباء عن المدينه بشكل كامل
اضافه الى مدينه قطع عنها الكهرباء بشكل
كامل مدينه القامش لا تزل حتى هذه لحظات
بدون كهرباء بينما مدينه ديريك عدت
الكهرباء الى بعض همم الاحياء المسيرات
التركيه المدعيه التركيه استهدفت البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه وسط مخاوف بان يعني
الملايين من السكان الذين يعيشون في مدن
شمال السوري قد يكونون امام كارثه انسانيه
مع يعني انقطاع الكهرباء الذي ادى الى
انقطاع مياه الشرب عن مدينه ديرك وعن
احياء واسعه في مدينه القاموس التي يقتلها
حوالي ربع مليون همم انسان اضافه الى تعطل
يعني جميع الدوائر الرس التابعه للاداره
الذاتيه يعني طلب من الموظفين عدم الذهاب
الى المدائ الى المدارس الى الجامعات
المعاهد البلديات ومراكز الصحافه بالتالي
مع وجود ازمه انسانيه حقيقيه قبل ال- ال-
الغارات وانتشار الكوليرا
عن عمليه بريه ايضا متوقعه من تركيا
الجانب التركي يؤكد هل من توقعات انه فعلا
هذه المره سيكون هناك تحرك او لا اريد
التاكيد فقط عن انه وزير الدفاع السابق لا
زال على قيد الحياه حتى الان معلومات
مؤكده
اليوم صباحا مع اداره الهلال الاحمر
الكردي في المشفى الذي يعالج فيه رزان كله
اكدوا لنا رزان يقول له لا يزال على قيد
الحياه لكنه يعاني جروح بليغه جميع
الاجراءات الاسعافات والعمليات التي اجريت
لها نجحت في قائمه على قيد الحياه لكن
حالته خطيره وفق ما
المعلومات التي حصلنا عليها من الهلال
الاحمر الكردي امام ميسون بخصوص التوغل
البري يبدو اا فعلا ان هناك يعني نيه
لتركيا
يعني بيتبول بريا على الاقل في مدينه
كوباني
ومنبج وفق ما سمعنا من قياده الاسد مصدوم
عبده هناك استعدادات عسكريه للقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فيها
المدينتين الكره تحدثنا عن همم التعبئه
العسكريه تحديدا في مدينه كوباني هناك
معلومات مؤكده الان فصيله من همم الجيش
الوطني لتركيا يجري مناورات على الارض
تحاكي تحاكي تواملا بريا محتملا همم شمال
همم
سوريا لذلك كنا نقرا
البنتاجون وايضا يعني زهره الخارجيه
الامريكيه التي طلبت فيهما تركيا بضبط نفس
وتفادي اي تغلغل
نعم
الى ردود الفعل جمعه بعد قليل ولكن
باختصار كان في انباء عن استهدافات قربه
مخيم الهول ايه خبرنا عن ما الذي استهدف
وما الذي كان متوقع تاثيره على الارض
باختصار بس
ليله همم
مدير المكتب الاعلامي لقاصد عن استهداف
نقطه حمايه نقطه
للاساير
تحدث في البدايه عن قرار بعض من الاسر ثم
في تغريده اخرى على تويتر طالب لانه تم
القاء القبض على
بعض من الاشخاص بعض من الدواعش الذين
هربوا منها همم لكن حتى الان ليس لدينا
يعني
استهدافه مباشره العربيه
طبعا كان زميلنا يتحدث عن ردود الفعل
وبالفعل في هذا الاطار وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اعرضت عن قلاقها البالغ اذا
القصف التركي الاخير على العراق وايضا
شمال سوريا اشارت الى ان تلك الاعمال
تزعزع استقرار المنطقه الخارجيه الامريكيه
حتى على الوقف الفوري لتصعيد شمال سوريا
وايضا اشارت في الوقت ذاته الى ان الاعمال
العسكريه شمال سوريا تهدد مهمه التصدي
لتنظيم داعش فيما اكدت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البنتاجون اكدت طبعا ان الضربات
الجويه التي تنفذها تركيا ونفذتها في
الاونه الاخيره في شمال سوريا تمثل تهديد
مباشر لسلامه العسكريين الامريكيين
البنتاجون طلبه بوقف صوري لاعمال التصعيد
مشيرا الى تفهم واشنطن لما وسطها بالمخاوف
الامنيه المشروعه لتركيا طبعا هذا التفاهم
الامريكي للمخاوف التركيه راى فيه البعض
نوع من التراخي في دعم ما قصد والتي قامت
بدورها بوقف التنسيق مع التحالف الدولي
والقتال ضد داعش بحسب تصريحات قائد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبد عبدي قال ان
الولايات المتحده لديها واجب اخلاقي
لثني الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن
اصدار امر بشان هجوم بري على شمال شرق
سوريا اضعف انه بالرغم من انه تلقى
معلومات استخباريه تؤكد طلب تركيا من
وكلاءها المحليين الاستعداد للهجوم البري
الا ان الاداره الامريكيه اداره الرئيس
بايدن لا زالت قادره على اقناع اردوغان
بالتراجع طبعا هذا بالنسبه للموقف
الامريكي همم بالنسبه الى روسيا فقد اكد
المبعوث الروسي الخاص الى سوريا
انطباع بان تركيا
ستمتنع عن شنه هجوم بري على سوريا وقال لي
وكاله نفوستي ان روسيا تقوم من خلال وزاره
الدفاع باقناع جميع الاطراف ضروره ضبط
النفس والابتعاد عن التصعيد اشار ايضا الى
موسكو مستعده لتنظيم لق الرئيسين السوري
طبعا هنا نتحدث بشار الاسد والتركي رجب
طيب اردوغان طبعا هذا بالنسبه للجانب
السوري والتطورات هناك اما العراق فقد
اعلن عزمه اعاده نشر قواته على حدوده مع
كل من ايران وايضا من تركيا هذا القرار
ياتي بعد ايضا القصف المتكرر الذي نفذته
طهران وانقره وطلع عدد من المناطق في
اقليم كردستان العراق الحكومه العراقيه
قالت في بيان صدره بعد اجتماع للمجلس
الوزاري للامن الوطني قالت انها قررت وضع
خطه لاعاده نشر القوات الحدود العراقيه
لمسك الخط الصفري على طول الحدود مع ايران
وتركيا اوضح البيان ان هذه الخطه س- توضع
بالتنسيق مع حكومه اقليم كردستان العراق
ووزاره البشمركه
مزيد معنا من الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني قبل ان ندخل
في تفاصيل الانتشار العراقي او الخطه التي
تم الاعلان عنها دعنا نتحدث عن التطورات
الميدانيه
في جميع مواقع او جميع المناطق الحدوديه
الشريط الحدود العراق التركي والشريط
العراقي مع ايران وطبعا هذا الهدوء حظر
طبعا ولم يكن هناك لم يسجل اي همم خارق او
اي قصف للطائرات لكن في ساعات الليل كنا
سمعنا بوضوح المسارات التركيه وهي تجوب
سماء مناطق المثلث العراق التركي الايراني
هو كنا نتوقع ان يكون هناك هجوم وقصف لكن
لم يكون هناك هجوم يبدو انها طائرات
مراقبه تراقب تحركات المعارضه التركيه في
المثلث العراقي التركي الايراني
عن الخطه العراقيه لنشر قواتها بدايه هل
من جدول زمني وضع
وخطه محدده لاليه العمل ونشر القوات
طبعا اشير الى ان هذا القرار هو في طبعا
هو في سابقه من نوع هذا القرار هو الاول
من نوعه بعد 2003 صحيح كان هناك قرارات
وانشاء لواء من حرس الحدود وقد نشر على
الحدود العراقيه التركيه لكن ليس في
المناطق الصخريه وليس على الحدود الدوليه
وطبعا هذا القرار جاء
على ما يبدو بالحاجه العراقيه لحفظ الحدود
العراقيه نتحدث عن 400 كيلو ميسون بدايه
تتحدث عن 400 كيلو متر طول الحدود
العراقيه الايرانيه همم مقابل لا يقيم
كردستان العراق فقط طبعا وايضا نتحدث عن
اكثر من 350 كيلو متر على طول الحدود
العراقيه التركيه بدها من مثلث العراق
التركي السوري نهايته عند شرق المثلث
العراقي التركي الايراني مناطق واعره جدا
فيها دعامات وفيها
دعامات مثبته للحدود قد كانت قد ثبتت
الحدود الدوليه في قبل اكثر من
من 20 عام تقريبا وايضا كان بعدها تنسيق
امني ما بين الطرفين ما بين العراق وتركيا
في تثبيت حدود لكن لا يوجد اي مخفر حدودي
اليوم بهذا القرار يكون القرار همم
طبعا لم يكن هناك على الارض اي تحرك حتى
الان هو مجرد همم اليه القرار ليست بالسهل
تطبيق او يحتاج ربما من سته اشهر في تقدير
لشخصين من سته اشهر كسوفي الى الى سنه كون
ان المناطق واعره جدا ولا وليس
عليها طرقات همم
لهذه القمم الجبال التي فيها التي فيها
دعامات حدوديه
واشارات حدوديه دوليه وبالتالي تحتاج
الطائرات العموديه في هذا طيب وسنتابع
التطورات من الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني مشاهدينا
سنكفي بهذا القدر من هذه الكلمه لنائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه طبعا هنا ملف
المختبرات البيولوجيه يعاد ليطرح كان كان
قد تم تقديم بعض وثائق للامم المتحده ولا
زال هناك الكثير تقدم روسيا بهذا الاطار
تنفيه اوكرانيا على كلن مشاهدينا ايه
اخبار الظهيره مستمره وفيها ولكن بعد قليل
انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان وقمع المحتجين على
طاوله البرلمان الاوروبي قومها
يعقد البرلمان الاوروبي اليوم جلسه
لمناقشه اوضاع المراه في ايران في ضل طبعا
انتهاكات النظام لحقوق الانسان وتواصل
والتظاهرات المناهضه له بعد مقتل الفتاه
مهس اميني بعد توقيفها من قبل ما يعرف
بالشرطه الاخلاق هذا بالنسبه للبرلمان
الاوروبي ايضا مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع
للامم المتحده في جنيف سيعقد اجتماع هو
الاخر خاص لاستعراض حاله الطوارئ الخاصه
بحقوق الانسان في ايران في ظل تصعيد الامن
للعنف ضد المحتاجين تعقد دول المجلس 47
اجتماع طارق لبحث تدهور وضع حقوق الانسان
وايضا القمع الدامي للتظاهرات والتي تهز
ايران بطلب اكثر من 50 دوله عضو في الامم
المتحده
بمبادره من المانيا وايضا ايسلندا
ادانات القمح الذي يفرضه النظام الايراني
على المحتجين تتولى على الصعيد الدولي
منظمه الامم المتحده نددت بما تقوم به
طهران في حق المتظاهرين مطالبه اياها
باقرار تعليق فوري لعقوبه الاعدام في عدد
الوفيات المتزايد جراء التظاهرات ومن
بينها وفاه طفلين في نهايه الاسبوع وتشديد
رد قوات الامن يشران الى ان الوضع خارج في
البلد يقول المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
المسؤول الاممي ذاته حتى طهرا على تلبيه
مطالب الشعب في المساواه والكرامه والحقوق
بدلا من استخدام القوه غير الضروريه وغير
المتكافئه لقمع الاحتجاجات وفق تعبيره من
بروكسل ايضا دعوه من اللجنه البلجيكيه
للبرلمانيين من اجل ايران ديمقراطيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاعضاء بادانه
ما وصفته بقتل المتظاهرين في ايران واتخاذ
اجراءات تقليديه عاجله وفرض عقوبات لوقف
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
هذا في وقت اتهمت مجموعه حقوقيه قوات
الامن الايرانيه باستخدام الرصاص الحي
واسلحه مختلفه لقمع المحتجين في المناطق
التي يقطنها الاكراد
هذا وحذر نشطاء من ان ايران تخطط لجعل
عقوبه الاعدام اداه لقمع الحركه
الاحتجاجيه عبر اشاعه مناخ من الخوف بلال
الوجداني العربيه
نور الدين الفريدي لحديث عن ما يحدث في
هذه الجلسه او سيحدث نور الدين اهلا بك هل
لك ان تعطينا فكره عن جدول الاعمال الجلسه
المرتقبه
اهلا ميسون النواب واعضاء لجنه العلاقات
بين البرلمان الاوروبي وايران والنواب
واعضاء لجنه المراه في البرلمان الاوروبيه
يبحثون او يبداون البحث بعد خمس دقائق من
الان موضوع تدهور الاوضاع حقوق الانسان
وهذا القمع المنهج من جانب السلطات
الايرانيه وخاصه الدوري الريادي الذي تطلع
به المراه الايرانيه في هذه الثوره
والثوره والعباره هنا التي استخدمها عدد
كبير من النواب الاوروبيين في تشخيصي ما
يجري في ايران همم خاصه وان المراه تمكنت
في بحر اسابيع من خلعي بعد القوانين
المقيله التي تقييد حريتها والتي تفريدها
عليها شرطه ايران الاخلاقيه البرلمانيه
الاوروبيه قال في بيانا قبل هذا الاجتماع
من ان اكثر من 300 ايراني قتلوا في هذه
المواجهات وان عدد غير محدد من المحتشين
حكم عليهم بالاعدام وهذا امر مرفوض من
جانب الاتحاد
ويعقده البرلمان الاوروبي
نعم نعم قرات عديده هذا الاجتماع هو
الثاني في بحر اسبوع يعقده البرلمان
الاوروبي حول تدهور الاوضاع في ايران
المسؤول السياسه الخارجيه جوزيف بوريل قال
امام البرلمان بالادانه الشديده لما يجري
وخاصه اكد على وجوب تشكيلي لجان لتقسي
الحقائق ودعم الجهود التي يبذلها مجلس
حقوق الانسان والذي سيبدا اجتماعاته بعد
نصف ساعه من الان في جنيف ومن بين الافكار
المطروحه تشكيل لجنه التحقيق وربما العمل
على تشكيل اليه قانونيه او قضائيه لمحاكمه
المسؤولين عن همم اعمال العنف ضد همم
اعمال العنف ضد المتظاهرين ومحليين مثل ما
تفضل الزميل في التقرير
120 نائبا من البرلمان البلجيكي يطالبون
الاتحاد الاوروبي بتشديد العقوبات ضد
السلطات يعني واي يطالبون ايضا في حاله
الملف في انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في ايران
الى مجلس الامن اذا تلاحظين همم ميسون ان
هناك هذا الزخم السياسي سواء كان محلي على
صعيد البرلمان او على الصعيد الدولي في
مجلس حقوق الانسان مش ناجلي الضغط على
السلطات الايرانيه والتي الى حد الان لم
تبدي اي مؤشر عن انفتاحها على المتظاهرين
او البحث عن حل سياسي بينما نرى ان اعمال
العنف تتزايد والثوره وتدخلوا شيئا فشيئا
مرحله من العنف الشديد بما معنى لا تدخل
مرحله الاغتيال
فيما يتعلق بلجنه تقص الحقائق باختصار ان
كانت ستكون على الارض في اليه اللي همم ان
تكون على الارض او امكانيه بالاحرى او عن
بعد
يعني لحد الان التجارب التي قام بها مجلس
حقوق الانسان قام به تحقيقات عده في مناطق
عده وان كان منها الاراضي الفلسطينيه او
او سوريا وهناك تقاسم الحقائق عن بعد
بالتالي هناك شهود وهناك ادله يتم جمع
سواء كان على الصعيد الرقمي او همم ان
الشهود بدون
بشهاداتهم امام امام المحققين امام
الخبراء سواء يمكن ان ينتقلوا الى الحدود
مع تركيا الى مناطق الى مناطق اخرى او عن
بعد او هناك بعض
الاساليب التي تتمكن المحتجون وخاصه من
ايطاليا صوتهم الى المحققين عندما تم
اتفاق على تشكيل لجنه لتقسي الحقائق في
مقتلني وما يجري من اعمال العنف شديد ضد
المتظاهرين في ايران واعتقالات اخرى ايضا
ان كان بالنسبه للمتظاهرين او حتى من
الاجانب من البروكس المراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريدي شكرا جزيلا لك طبعا ما
يتعلق بالتاكيد القضاء الايراني توقيف
عشرات الاجانب على صله بالاحتجاجات اعلنت
هولندا انها عاجزه عن الاتصال القنصلي
بمواطن هولندي معتقل في الداخل الايراني
الحكومه الهولنديه قالت في رساله للبرلمان
قالت انه من المؤسف ان لا تكون السلطات
الايرانيه قد اتاحت بعد امكانيه الاتصال
القنصلي لهذا المعتقل الهولندي السلطات
الايرانيه كانت اعلنت توقيفه تسعه اجانب
احدهم هولندي بتهمه الارتباط بالحركه
الاحتجاجيه وبينما تتهم السلطات الايرانيه
تتهم المانيا فرنسا تتهم ايطاليا ايضا
وبولندا بالتدخل في هذه الاحتجاجات طبعا
بحسب عدد من الصحف الايرانيه المحافظه
قالت الحكومه الهولنديه في رسالتها ان
ايران لم تقدم اي دليل على ما تقول انه
تدخل اجنبي في هذه الاحتجاجات نقلت
الرساله ونقلت عن وزير الخارجيه الهولندي
الذي قال ان الاتهامات بتدخل بلاده في هذه
الاحتجاجات اوردها عدد من الصحف الايرانيه
المحافظه طبعا تستمر عمليه توثيق التعاطي
الايراني مع الاحتجاجات سلطه تقرير لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه الضوء على الطرق
التي يتبعها النظام في قمع الاحتجاجات
طبعا هذا التقرير اشار الى ان قوات الامن
استعانق بسيارات الاسعاف
للتسلل الى قلب المظاهرات واحتجاز
المشاركين فيها بين الصحيفه انها تلقت عدد
من الروايات من قبل شهود عيان وذلك في
اوائل اكتوبر الماضي حول استخدام سيارات
الاسعاف وانها تحققت من بعض مقاطع الفيديو
التي اثبتت صحه ما قالوه اضافه الصحيفه ان
المزاعم بدات تتكشف اتباعا بعد ما افاد
احد سكان طهران اوائل الشهر الماضي بانه
راى ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه متظاهرين يتم
الزاج بهم في سياره اسعاف خلال مظاهره
قادها الطلاب موضحا ان المتظاهرين لم
يكونوا مصابين على ما يبدو
[موسيقى]
طبعا تحدثنا على المستوى الميداني اما على
المستوى السياسي فقد وصفت السفاره الروسيه
في الولايات المتحده وصفت نهج واشنطن
بالعداء بعد اعلان وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه عن سعيها للتعاون مع مواطنين
روس ضد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
السفاره عبر التلغرام اعلنت ان نائب مدير
وكالات الاستخبارات الامريكيه اعترفوا
بشكل عالمي ان الوكاله تبحث عن عملاء قالت
ان الوكاله تقوم بنشاط معادن لروسيا وانها
تحاول زعزعه استقرار روسيا وايضا التدخل
في شؤونها اذا الاستخبارات تدخل على حرب
روسيه اوكرانيه بدات في الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير الماضي بدات معها اطراف خارجيه
بالمشاركه في النساء الشيشان احد تلك
الاطراف التي شاركت بفريقين مختلفين واحد
موالي لروسيا واخر لاوكرانيا المزيد في
هذا الطريق
هل تشعل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا شراره
حرب اهليه شيشانيه جديده الرئيس شيشاني
رمضان قديره زج بنفسه في مشهد الصراع
الروسي الاوكرانيه يفتخر تاره بنشر قوته
في اوكرانيا استجابه لمطالب الرئيس الروسي
بلادي مربوطن وتاره اخرى يحض الاوكرانيين
على الاطاحه بحكمتهم
وحدهم من استقطبتهم الحرب فهناك على الضفه
الاخرى شيشانيون مناهضون لقديروبا وجدوه
في الحرب الدائره على اراضي اوكرانيا فرصه
للقتال ضد روسيا التي يعتبرونها عدوهم
الاول قبل نحو 22 عاما كان شيشانيون
يخوضون حربهم الاخيره من اجل استقلال
بلادهم عن روسيا حرب انتهت دون ان تحقق
اهدافها بالنسبه الى الجمهوريه القوقازيه
بل ادت الانقسام الشيشانيين الى فريقين
فريق الاول استسلم للحكم الروسي وان صاع
لسيطره رئيس البلاد الجديد رمضان قدير
وفريق ثاني حافظ على اعدائه للرؤوس مواصل
مواجهاته معهم على طريقه حرب العصابات
شكل هؤلاء المعارضون الشيشانيون النواه
الاولى لنقل الصراع الداخليه الشيشاني الى
شرق اوكرانيا وانخرطوا في صفوف الفرق
العسكريه من خلال كتيبتين اساسيتين كتيبه
جوهر دبايب وكتيبه الشيخ منصور
الى هذه الوحدات الاوكرانيه المقاتله خوفا
من عقوبات قانونيه لكونهم يحملون جنسيات
دول اوروبيه
في اوروبا وجدوا انفسهم هناك بعد الحربين
في الشيشان حصل معظمهم على جنسيته دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وان لم تلاحقهم عقوبات الدول الاوروبيه قد
يجدون انفسهم يواجهونه هم او اقاربهم
احتماليه الوقوع بيد قديره ومواجهه نهايه
الماساويه
من الشيشان من الذين يقاتلون مع
الاوكرانيين يخفون هوياتهم بسبب خوفهم على
اقاربهم ومن الاعدامات الجماعيه والقمع
بالنسبه لهؤلاء المقاتلين الشيشان الحرب
مساله شخصيه من جهه يقاتلون ابناء جلدتهم
الواقفين الى جانب روسيا وينظرون اليهم
كخونه ومن جهه اخرى لتصفيه حسابات قديمه
مع بوتل على امل ان تكون الحرب بدايه
النهايه لعدوهم القديم
الا الملف اليمني الان حيث اكد وزير
الخارجيه اليمنيه احمد عوض بن مبارك اكد
ان جماعه الحوثي لم تفلت من العقاب مشيرا
الى ان تصنيفها جماعه ارهابيه لن يؤثر على
اعمال الاغاثه بالبلاد بالمباركه اوضح ان
الحكومه اليمنيه تعكس على اعداد قائمه
سوداء باسماء قياده وكيانات حوثيه لملاحقه
مصالحهم وشبكاته بالماليه في مختلف انحاء
العالم مشددا في الوقت نفسه على ان
استمرار تصعيد الحوثيين سيجعل الحكومه
اليمنيه توصل العمل مع حكومات العالم
لاقناعها بتصنيفهم جماعه ونبقى في الرياضه
ومعي من دبي وحيد المصري الصحفي في قسم
الرياضه في قناه العربيه اهلا بك وحيد
اسمح لي ان ابدا بما حدث بالامس هل
المفاجاه كانت همم خساره المانيا او فوز
اليابان
مرحبا فيك ميسون وطبعا المباراه كانت
مفاجاه مدويه ثاني مفاجاه في نهايه كاس
العالم الحاليه بعد فوز المنتخب السعودي
على الارجنتين كما شاهدنا ممكن اعتبارا
مفاجاه بالصناعه المانيه هسمت الالمان
الرقم اللطيف كان انه في قائمه منتخب
اليابان في الامس او في المونديال بشكل
عام وجد ثمانيه لاعبين محترفين في انديه
المانيه لاعبين يابانيين منهم سبعه في
القسم الاول البوندسليغا المستوى الاول
واثنان اللاعبان اللذان سجل الهدفين الفوز
اليابان على المانيا شركا كبديلين وهما
ايضا يلعبان في انديه المانيا في فرانبو
وفيبوخهم تحديدا يعني تدربوا عرفوا السر
الالماني وهزم الالمان ايضا يعني خساره
مضاعفه اذا ما صح التعبير ماذا عن اليوم
والاعين كلها ربما على رونالدو الالماني
بهذه النتيجه وباللاعبين المحترفين لدي
الذين سببه هزيمه المنتخب الوطني للبلاد
طيب كنت سالتك عن رونالدو الاعين تتجه
اليك سيظهر اليوم برايك
طبعا رونالدو كما نعلم بسبب عمره 37 سنه
قد يكون هذا اخر مونديال له مونديال
المقبل بعد اربع سنوات 41 عام قد لا يكون
مستمرا في الملاعب او في نفس العطاء الذي
يقدمه بالتالي يجب ان يتفادى ما حدث في
الايام السابقه
لغريمه وندوا اعلاميه على الاقل ليونيل
ميسي مهمه لن تكون سهله اليوم سيواجه
منتخب غانا البرتغال
والمثير انه في احد لاعبي منتخب غانا 22
عام محمد قدوس المحترف في اياكس قدوته هو
كريستيانو رونالدو عندما سيرته في الملاعب
حد يشاهد اليوم اللاعب الذي كان قدوه
رونالدو يسبب هزيمه البرتغال ورونالدو
طبعا
الامور لمصلحه البرتغال لكن كما شاهدنا في
كاس العالم حاليا
شيء وما يحدث بعدها من مجهود ومردود من
اللاعبين امر مختلف تماما
القضيه في هذه المفاجات انه طفره فقط او
انه لا في مشروع واضح وصريح يبدو
طبعا الميزه في في كره القدم انك تحتاج
الى مشروع مشروع متكامل يبدا من اتحاد
يبدا من مواهب من مدرب يقود المنتخب لبضع
سنوات على الاقل جميع العناصر تكون مكتمله
المفاجات ممكن تحدث في بعض الالعاب برمي
طائشه لكن في كره قدم لا يمكن ان تحدث
المفاجاه الا بمشروع متكامل شاهدنا بعض
المنتخبات ايضا في التصنيف الثالث او
الرابع في هذه البطوله تتلقى هزاء كبيره
كوستاريكا لم يكن لديها مشروع واضح لم يكن
لديها لاعبين اقوياء في محترفين في انديه
اوروبيه فتلقت هزيمه كبيره مع اسبانيا
بينما منتخبات اخرى لديها رؤيه واضحه
لماسه تقدم ليست فقط قادمه للمشاركه وانما
لاثبات نفسها وقدمت هذا المشروع والنجاح
كان امام الملايين عبر الشاشات التلفاز
وفي الملاعب
كان معنا من دبي وحيد المصري الصحفي في
قسم الرياضه في قناه العربيه شكرا جزيلا
لك
الى تونس الان حيث اجلت محكمه الجناح
الابتدائيه التونسيه النظر في القضيه
المتعلقه بعقود اللبنج لوبين عذرا
المنسوبه الى رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي والمكلف بالعلاقات الخارجيه داخل
الحركه رفيق عبد السلام الغنوشي لم يحضر
طبعا جلسه امس فيما قررت هيئه الدائره
تاخير النظر في القضيه الى شهر يناير
المقبل يواجه المتهمين الغنوشي وعبد
السلام توها من تتعلق بتلقي تمويل خارجي
مجهول المصدر وقبول تمويل الاجنبيه
فردات السلطات في مدينه
عمان
السلطات المحليه قالت انه لم يعد يسمح
لسكان وسط المدينه بمغادره المنطقه من دون
ابراز نتيجه سلبيه لاختبار كورونا نصحتهم
بعدم مغادره منازلهم الا عند الضروره
واضافت السلطات ان هذه القيود ستسرع
اعتبارا لمده خمسه ايام على اكثر من 6 من
6 ملايين شخص اي نصف سكان المدينه تقريبا
الى نادين الان واخبار الظهيره الاقتصاديه
مدينه فضلها
اهلا بكم
بجوله على تداولات الاسواق كما هي بالوقت
الحاضر فاذن اليوم الصوره متباينه باسواق
منطقه الخليج ولكن بالشكل الاساسي يبدو
انه اسعار النفط هي التي تضغط على الاسواق
اسعار النفط على تراجع حد منذ يوم امس
هناك الكثير ما يجري بالسوق النفطيه والذي
يؤثر على الاسعار بدوره يؤثر على الاسواق
الخليجيه هذه اسعار النفط خام برنت عن 85
دولار 78 دولار لماذا هذه التراجعات كنا
يعني قبل ايام عم نحكي عن 95 دولار على
مزاج براند اولا هناك قصه نتبعها
باوروبايه اللي هي توجه الجي 7 مجموعه
الدول السابعه للفرض سقف على صادرات روسيا
من النفط والغاز لمعاقبتها على الحرب في
اوكرانيا همم الموضوع هو انه ليس هناك من
اتفاق المفوضيه الاوروبيه كان من المفترض
يوم امس ان تحدد السعر اللي هو السقف لا
تستطيع روسيا ان تبعه النفط فوقه ولكن لم
يتم التواصل الى اتفاق لماذا لانه تم
تسريب خبر الى رويترز انه السقف من حكى
فيه هو 65 الى 70$ على عق- على عقود
الاورالزيه اللي هو النفط الروسي الذي
تصدره روسيا بحرا فاذن همم هي حاليا
تبيعها هذا النفط بحدود 63 ل 64$ يعني اقل
من هذا السقف في بعض الاعضاء بالاتحاد
الاوروبيه يبدون سعر اعلى البعض ودون سعر
اقل بالتالي هناك عدم توافق تم تاجيل
الموضوع الى اليوم اليوم في اجتماع
للوزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين مساء وقد يمتد
الامر الى غدا لانه التطبيق من المفترض ان
يكون بخامس من ديسمبر من ناحيه اخرى ايضا
في عدم توافق على فرض همم سعر على الغاز
روسي سقف على الغاز الروسيه وايضا هناك
عدم توافق هذا كله بالاضافه الى امكانيه
المخاوف من ركود اقتصادي يضغط على اسعار
النفط وبالتالي على اسواق منطقتنا لننقراض
على اسواق الخليج بالوقت الحاضر سوق
السعوديه على تراجع بثلاث ارباع النقطه
المئويه دبي وابو ظبي عالمي للتراجع السوق
الكويتيه على ارتفاع في ظل اخبار اندماج
هناك ما بينكين همم وهذا بالسعوديه ال-
الذي يحدث اليوم مرافق اول يوم يتم تداول
اسومها في السوق السعوديه هي مرافق
للكهرباء والمياه الشركه التي تقدم خدمات
الكهرباء والمياه للمجمعات الصناعيه
بالجبيل وبينبع تم تحديد سعر الاي بي او
على 46 ريال اليوم وصل ل52 باعلى سعر ولكن
الان يتداول على 48 ريال اعلى باربعه
بالمئه من سعر على اي بي او هذا نتبعه
بالسعوديه ايضا نتبع اسهم سابك اللي عم
تدرس انشاء مجمع براس الخير لتحويل همم
النفط وسوائله الى كيماويات من المفترض
التحويل 400,000 برميل يوميا من النفط الى
الكيماويات سهم سابك الان على ارتفاع اقوى
باور نتبعها هي سابقا كانت اعلنت انها
توا- اعاده شراء سندات لها مصدره في السوق
بقيمه 400 مليون دولار رفعت حجم الشراء
الان الى 428 مليون دولار السهم على بعض
وترجع بالكويت عندنا ارتفاع في بنك هما
بنك الخليج والاهل الكويتي كان في سابقا
مفاوضات اندماج الجديد الان انه حصلوا على
موافقه البنك المركزي على تعيين مستشارين
قيم بدراسه الجدول للاندماج بينهما
السهمان على ارتفاع سنكتفي بهذا القدر
اعود القاكم في الاسواق العربيه بعد قليل
عوده اليك ميسون الان والاخبار
شكرا نادين الى العناوين
مراسل العربيه يؤكد نجاه وزير الدفاع سابق
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه استهدف بقصف تركي
في القامشلي
واشنطن تحت انقره على وقف التصعيد شمال
سوريا والعراق ينشر قواتها على الحدود
نلتقي غدا شكله متابعه مشاهدينا ابقوا
معنا